vorrei iniziare italiano sessioni che un
articolo su repubblica di domenica 14
febbraio a firma di jessica werner
stesso e proponi ha suscitato in me che
partono dalla constatazione che qualcosa
di nuovo sta accadendo universalmente a
proposito di quello che fino a non molto
tempo fa rappresentava un caposaldo dei
processi di formazione dell'identità
mi riferisco al appartenenti al sesso
femminile a maschile al processo di
identificazione che ne deriva sono in
atto processi di cambiamento linguistico
introdotti in varie situazioni che
stanno ad indicare come non sia più
possibile considerare solo laminarie ta
di genere spesso ciò accade che nella
lingua parlata ho scritto è
rappresentativo di mutamento sociale
certificato e come tale foriero anche di
applicazioni psiche ma partiamo da
qualche esempio alcuni membri
dell'americana in esso sia ai pini hanno
proclamato parola dell'anno libro nome
dei che l'associazione di pronome neutro
o singolare cioè per indicare una
persona di cui non viene detto se
maschio oppure femmina o di cui non si
conosce l'identità in generale molto
università americana nel prodotto
pronomi come se phone che volevo
sottolineare la possibilità che noi ora
solamente semplicemente al sistema
minare di genere maschile
per non parlare di nis alternativa
mister ho visto che recentemente è stato
aggiunto nello score english dictionary
contemporamente intenti di è stata
proclamata parola dell'anno dati
schengen e punto com
secondo la candore datrice cioè infette
la consapevolezza sempre che 50
dell'opinione pubblica nelle nuove
espressioni di genere così potrebbe
aggiungerebbe la ricerca sempre più
accentuata di una propria specifica
connotazione in un tempo che ha fatto
della crew in vita uno dei suoi caposala
facebook sempre molto attenta al
marketing
fra i suoi utenti offre nei 50 diverse
identità frati si può scegliere il
genere fluido e di genere addirittura la
cenere certamente se possiamo
riconoscere in questo episodio nel
segmento politicamente corretto per
accattivarsi l'opinione pubblica e in
particolare quella fascia di popolazione
che sta avendo sempre più voce in
capitolo non possiamo trascurare gli
effetti che questo sommovimento avrai in
termini di informazione psichica
trattandosi comunque di un processo
ripulisce nel conscio del tipo
individuale né possiamo abbandonare le
riflessioni sul tema pensando che si
tratti semplicemente è un fenomeno che
riguarda proprio sastri in un mondo
perennemente interconnesse non è più
possibile operare ad estensioni
cosiddette buona sera io sono stefania
carta segno e sono una donna transgender
mentre scrivevo queste frasi e cercavo
di estrapolare un po da internet i
contenuti sorridevo andando poi a
recuperare nella mia memoria quei luoghi
della mia adolescenza quando circa
all'età di 15 16 anni mi sono dovuto
imbattere proprio con il mio maschile
con il mio femminile andando un po a
cozzare pesantemente su quello che
poteva essere una scelta o certo è
sicuramente che l'aia allora il
desiderio di poter fare uscire la mia
parte femminile fu potentissimo e il
desiderio di s
conosciuta da una società che a fatica
per stereotipi per condizionamenti ad
accogliere qualcosa di fortemente
diverse un po la mia battaglia al mio
mio percorso viola e allora di certo non
sapevo che cosa sarei diventata ho
cercato di intuirlo un po nel tempo
sicuramente intorno ai 20 e 21 anni ho
sentito l'esigenza o forse ho iniziato a
sognare la possibilità che un giorno
qualcuno magari non avrebbe vissuto
quello che stavo vivendo io ho iniziato
a pensare che forse magari la grande
forse se avrei trovato la possibilità di
costruire un giardino un luogo protetto
in cui tutta la comunità lgbt cui
potesse sentirsi accolta potesse
sentirsi libera di esprimersi nella sua
manifestazione nella sua straordinaria
variopinta identità di genere essere
identità nasce circa cinque anni fa nel
2012 dall'insieme di un gruppo di
persone che sono in realtà eterogenee
senza un'identità per forza di cose che
fa parte questo acronimo e nasce con
l'intento di portare in superficie di
sensibilizzare di offrire a tutta la
popolazione una cultura della differenza
è un modo nuovo per potersi approcciare
proprio a alla diversità e noi come lo
facciamo lo facciamo attraverso una
serie di progetti che portiamo in giro
nelle scuole negli enti nella su tutto
il territorio siamo un po una oasi del
piemonte del basso piemonte che appunto
offre una serie di servizi che vanno da
da un'oasi di ascolto uno sportello da
una serie di progetti che noi portiamo
avanti all'interno delle scuole
ma proprio due settimane fa all'interno
di una di queste scuole qui in
alessandria in cui abbiamo fatto un
intervento il 17 maggio è la giornata
internazionale contro l'omo transfobia e
abbiamo proposto il film di veronica
pivetti e rappresenta anche lei come
autrice e come presentatrice del film
alla fine i ragazzi alcuni e il corpo
insegnanti ci ha detto ma è ancora
necessario parlare di omosessualità di
transessualità siete sgamate in fondo
cioè di cosa stiamo a parlare
beh dopo cinque giorni ad alba un padre
aspettato il fidanzato del proprio
figlio ad una pompa di benzina e con una
mazza da baseball gli ha spaccato la
testa
a noi piace pensare ma non grazie non
soltanto a noi ma sono innumerevoli gli
psicologi lingiardi e uno dei psicologi
più famosi italiani che appunto è forte
in giro la teoria dell'identità ci piace
pensare che l'identità realta non sia
qualcosa di fisso un'istanza fissa ma
noi siamo molto di più di quello che in
realtà è la nostra identità sessuale
e i caposaldi sono proprio questi e la
sessualità si sviluppa attraverso anzi
scusate l'identità sessuale diventa di
genero l'ora di generi l'orientamento
sessuale il comportamento sessuali sono
proprio questi paradigmi su cui l'essere
umano si fonda
allora ma questo acronimo lgbt qui che è
tanto usato ma che spesso è confuso che
cosa sa indicare indica le persone
lesbiche gay bisessuali transessuali
queer e intersessuali emisfero magari un
pochettino di più a raccontarvi che cosa
possa essere la parola queer e la parola
inter sessuale proprio perché in realtà
tutte le altre sono già state un po
sgamate qui viene utilizzato un po come
se fosse un termine ombrello nel quale
le persone si collocano quando non hanno
proprio la necessità di doversi sentire
da una parte o dall'altra in un'identità
di genere di un certo tipo
oppure in un comportamento affettivo
sessuale di un altro tipo
ecco che appunto come dicevamo prima
proprio perché la sessualità è qualcosa
che fonde più aspetti insieme queste
persone scelgono di essere identificate
con questo termine
e mentre la parola intersessuale
rappresenta le persone che nascono con
entrambi gli apparati riproduttivi
la cosa che mi sconvolge è che conobbi
tanti anni fa un medico che mi racconto
questo aneddoto aveva appena incontrato
la madre di un bambino intersessuale
perciò con entrambi gli apparati entro
cinque giorni
e necessario che il genitore scelga il
sesso del figlio
pensate questa cosa quanto possa essere
delicata problematica quando quando poi
la sessualità che essendo appunto
qualcosa che si trasforma e l'identità
si costruisce nel tempo forse magari da
grande sarà anche altro identità
sessuali la conosciamo tutti nasciamo
basket oppure femminucce
ma che cos'è l'identità di genere
evidente adige né riguarda la sensazione
intima e profonda la convinzione
permanente precoce di essere uomo o
donna
io nacqui con quell'involucro dentro un
corpo maschile marine percezioni e le
mie sensazioni i miei pensieri
le mie creazioni non erano quelle
maschili erano quelle femminili
il ruolo di genere è l'insieme dei
comportamenti agiti all'interno delle
relazioni con gli altri e delle
attitudini che in seno a un dato
contesto storico culturale sono
riconosciuti come propri i maschi o
delle femmine
dunque se sono una donna e scelgo di
fare il camionista possa continuare a
essere una donna
se sono una transessuale che ha scelto
di cambiare il suo sesso ma decido di
fare il pugile posso farlo purtroppo
come voi sapete benissimo ai
condizionamenti sociali impediscono
sperso influire di questa ferme
naturalezza e poi abbiamo un
orientamento sessuale affettivo che è
un'attrazione un attrazione erotica
dunque qualcosa che mi spinge verso
l'alto perché desidero l'altro come
oggetto di desiderio sessuale oppure
affettivo di un individuo verso un altro
e quindi definisce l'oggetto e propri
impulsi ma il comportamento sessuale
ancora altro perché il comportamento è
quello che fa sì che io scelga col mio
compagno di giocare più o meno in un
certo modo e non è sicuramente quel
gioco che fa di me quella persona
ecco che credo ognuno di noi passa
magari per una volta di essersi sentito
un po così un maschio magari incapace di
piangere o forse magari giudicato perché
lo sta facendo
perché essere dei maschi piangono forse
vuol dire andare a grattare dentro
quella parte di sé un po femminile o
forse una donna che magari solo perché
ha delle qualità magari più determinate
non è per questo debba essere
considerata un uomo lo stereotipo
purtroppo è uno dei primi processi
mentali che avviene nel momento in cui
non ci troviamo di fronte a qualcuno ma
noi sappiamo bene che se da una parte lo
stereotipo è un po una sorta di
strumento
che ci permette di ottimizzare più
velocemente i nostri pensieri
se io vedo una macchina gialla che corre
per la strada probabilmente io so che a
un taxi ma se si cristallizza quell idea
se quel pensiero resta lì fisso ecco che
mi impedisce di potere fare un passo
successivo
ecco che allora nello stereotipo la
comunità lgbt cui viene sempre vista in
un certo modo
l'omosessuale quello timido ma io vi
assicuro conosco un sacco di omosessuali
per noi la timidi e oppure per niente
simpatici oppure la transgender o la
transessuale è quella e che magari a una
vita peccaminosa oppure che vive ai
margini della società che cosa succede
se noi non superiamo questo limite
mentale e questo pensiero si
cristallizza accade che da un da uno
stereotipo si passi ad un pregiudizio e
lo dice parola per la parola stessa
pregiudizio io ho un giudizio affrettato
ma qui si entra già più a che fare con
un atteggiamento allora non mi fermo
soltanto nel mondo delle idee ma inizio
a dire sì sì questa persona di colore
che mi sia che mi siede vicino forse è
un ladro mi sposto e me ne vado
ed ecco che a questo punto si inserisce
proprio un azione verso quell altra
persona
il passaggio successivo è la
discriminazione cioè io agisco un
comportamento perseverante nei confronti
di quella persona o una determinata
etnia o un gruppo e lo escludo
completamente con delle conseguenze
purtroppo questo è quello che succede
spesso il 17 di maggio di ogni anno è il
giorno
come dicevo prima della giornata
internazionale della transfobia e vi
dico una cosa in realtà io conosco ho
conosciuto molte persone omofobe e ho
conosciuto anche molti omosessuali e
omofobi
in realtà lo sono state anche io lo sono
stati
sono stata sia omofoba e transfobica
perché nel momento in cui mi relazione
con l'altro per poter accogliere l'altro
nella sua diversità non posso non aveva
fatto i conti con la mia diversità di
non avere fatto anche un po di pace con
la mia diversità
ecco che succede credo sia successo
almeno una volta nella vita tutti voi
quello di magari giudicare una persona
perché non vi piace e forse riconoscere
che nel tempo non vi piaceva perché
aveva qualcosa che ti apparteneva e quel
qualcosa è una cosa con cui non si fa
fatti non si fa molta molta amicizia non
si fa più fatica ad entrare in contatto
purtroppo omofobia aloma trans oppure la
transfobia si può fermare solo quello
oppure sì si può trasformare in atti
concreti di discriminazioni nel 1963
l'american psichiatriche sociali shaun
derubrica la diagnosi di omosessualità
del manuale diagnostico e statistico
delle malattie mentali
oggi il transessualismo non è ancora
derubricato si lavora per questo
e io mi auguro di poter essere un giorno
tolta da questo antipatico manuale
all'orientamento sessuale è una scelta
hai usato queste immagini dove però voi
probabilmente non vedrete i due
cagnolini finali quello di destra e
quello di sinistra che sono neri perché
vi assicuro che sia avessi potuto
scegliere non avrei scelto di essere una
donna transgender
non avrei scelto perché questa è una
strada in salita
sarebbe molto stato più semplice
scegliere da che parte stare
anche perché purtroppo le persone l'uomo
la donna non si interrogano in realtà su
cui sono una donna nasce dall inizio ad
avere i propri impulsi e il proprio
orientamento nei confronti del sesso a
posto e difficilmente andrà a grattare
all'interno la ricerca di se stessa alla
ricerca di un identità più profonda
nella nostra comunità nel mondo lgbt cui
questo accade spesso è quasi un fil
rouge che ci accomuna un po tutti
la comunità lgbt cui mondiale stimata
intorno al 5 per cento su 400 mila
abitanti nella provincia 20.000 solo
lgbt cui credo che questo dato sia un
dato su cui bisogna riflettere perché
vuol dire che è necessario oggi creare
delle condizioni ottimali cultura nella
di fede la differenza proprio per
offrire a questo numero cosi alto un
luogo di accoglienza e di sicurezza
io vi lascio con questa riflessione
donna non si nasce lo si diventa e
ritorno proprio pensare che proprio
perché noi siamo molto di più di quello
che crediamo di essere varrebbe la pena
che ognuno propria andare a scandagliare
una sonda dentro di sé forse magari
trovare in una donna la propria parte
maschile potrebbe voler dire avere un po
più più di polso e provare la prima
parte simile in un uomo un pò più di
capacità di ascolto vi ringrazio
stefania cappa segno